ladies and gentlemen it's Wednesday I
want to say this right away dude it's
it's it's pop your [ __ ] wins its pop
[ __ ] Wednesday it's adorable Wednesday
Phoenix this Saturday I'm at the
celebrity theater come check it out it's
gonna be a hell of a show frank
caliendo's opening up adam ray is gonna
be there then Boston Wilbur theater the
31st New Year's Eve I'm there
come one come all let's rock and roll I
will be making you laugh Brennan where
you gonna be you also suck them yep I
ain't a sucka
I'm in La Jolla this Thursday Friday
Saturday La Jolla The Comedy Store my
favorite Club and then next week I'm in
Oklahoma City
on the 27th two shows and then Tulsa
Hard Rock Casino in Tulsa and just
announced New Year's Eve I'm spending at
the ice house in Pasadena
one show at 8 o'clock one show at 10
o'clock bring in 2020 the right way with
your boy into my funny ass friends
that's the ice house for New Year's Eve
get your tickets just one on sale today
those will sell out so get them now then
January is coming in super [ __ ]
steamy y'all Connecticut Foxwoods casino
January 10th then I'm in Boston January
11th Wilbur 50 tickets left at the
Wilbur and then San Jose January 17th
through the 19th get your tickets now at
T fat K calm well guess what it's it's
hot money Monday
Simon adorable I mean hot money
Wednesday and it's adorable adorable one
day huh cat couldn't look more adorable
Chin's covered his head he's got the tea
fat K jacket on and hoodie yup you've
got all kinds of patches on your thing
I'm wearing a [ __ ] alert and tighter
and tighter shirt and you gave me a nice
company said you look pretty much like
postal mail bees now yeah what you know
careful what well no you I told you I
gave a commoner dude have you put on
some lean muscle yeah once you feel good
yeah light a tad you look the exact same
nope but I want you feel good I say no
cuz you miss Monday miss Monday and
usually you know been a little tough
theorem for all daddy here's a couple
things waking up super early I don't do
well with that no matter when I go to
bed daddy can't wake up at 5:30 it's a
big problem for me I'm a night person my
life whatever then daddy did some some
some exercises
my friend Rudy was helping me out and I
did this thing and I pull a little
muscle on my lover back old drinks has a
wrinkle in the neck ole drinks has some
old injuries right we all have those
little compromises in our body sometimes
you you do a little like that and you go
ah that that that's gonna be five days
and worse nagging that dude that's right
there's nothing and you know right away
it goes like that sometimes sometimes
I'll go it'll go and I go okay hold on
didn't blow away I lie down back I lie
down I lie down I relax it and I'm good
but I have to lie down right away and
relax dude daddy hasn't been getting any
sleep either that's why you and I both
look like [ __ ] oh you haven't sleepy
neither new baby okay is a stomach issue
we doesn't take formula so he's
basically lactose intolerant as a
newborn so that's fun okay he's liking
calories how can can and so he's crying
a ton
now daddy is a night nurse that is night
nurse you got a night nurse you know
night nurse however you know she comes
pretty late yeah so as soon as I get
home and I get up with them you know
it's just yeah now look now hold on now
the whole family sick too now okay we
look like Asians everyone has a mask on
in the house that's because you can't
get the baby sick so everyone looks like
this yeah so then I was like oh I'm
getting a little sick I got my shows in
La Jolla I'm like I cannot get sick huh
so daddy's decided to try to go to bed
early after you get done from The Comedy
Store last night my early I mean
midnight he'll give you up at 5:00
that's good I took nyquil hmm feels good
in the morning doesn't it you don't feel
like you're you don't feel like your
heads in wet cement at all who'd your
vet cement at all what is nyquil though
it's it's a narcotic it [ __ ] you up
it's what it does it makes you tired
what they give the animals in the zoo oh
dude it's dude I was so groggy oh oh you
just can't get going and and dice up my
son's finally potty training he's
wearing underwear we have to be on this
time on Monday he goes pop I won't we
were big boy and he's like yo Mike how
fantastic is that sick of changing
diapers so he's an underwear now and
it's in this morning I woke up all
groggy meet him pee first thing in the
morning now usually you'd think it'd be
the three-year-old who's
and all over the walls and see nope this
morning was palpable some spray nyquil
and he goes papa it's getting everywhere
it's uh so weird that example I pissed
all over them my piss hole is my piss
hole you ever when when a girl's the
reasons a girl sits down to pee is
because it sprays all over the place I
have a vagina piss hole oh well I
sometimes it'll just go to that it'll
shoot into two different streams because
things get off because they've smashed
in the old underwear yeah I know I
didn't show you like ah [ __ ] and some of
its on the floor yeah I don't have a PF
you bust nuts it's very weird to the
tubing first string because all of these
well yeah I kind of like it's like this
cool kind of it's almost like one of
those spitting that's right
venomous pythons were the [ __ ] getting a
spitting cobra yeah like yeah spitting
cobra and it's just like yep yep all
over the place
that's why I was me this morning my
sassy Cobra my son goes daddy you're
splashing all over the place dude chill
huh maybe yeah maybe yeah get get mommy
to get that breast milk going just you
know ever just do some baby on your big
tasty some of them big teddy well one
thing about women on the ways I've only
had a child with one woman
my my wife and she she a big she would
wake up she would wake up hey yeah you
Manning a big tail yeah yeah of course
she's yes and she was already she was
already well put to get out and so she
but that she would wake up that baby
would go like that and she would be out
right away
right up I'd be like I couldn't move
women have this crazy sense connection
with their baby where they're just like
you're the connectome like Avatar like
it's amazing that they're like avatar
that's that's oxytocin which is a
bonding chemical they're on drugs it's
deep it's sparking yep you need it you
need it otherwise you knew who I wish
was my dad and I've never met him before
and he's hands-down the nicest community
met my life hold on hold on you want him
to be your dad willing to be my dad he's
a really nice comedian the nicest I've
ever met and he's off
so very famous he's also worked with the
best in the business opened up for Chris
Rock worked with Lucy cave Zilber is Tim
Allen not absolutely not okay but I die
to get out I'm making make funny because
he is older so I'd be like a dad figure
now I mean him might be the same age
Nicky oh that's key okay is you threw me
off with the dad by now he's my I want
to be my dad I think was young major
he's actually no way think mates type it
and see what how old is he Jen babies
old I buy a year right 40 40 so I'm I'm
36 so he could have had me when he was
four good good good man he's a good man
first of all phenomenal comic are you
had a Nashville he's a father as well
awesome way to go face a little fat
there yeah
and he's lost some weight looks
fantastic I didn't really recognize him
as fresh because he did him off stage we
bullied him in the in the hallway well
you bullied oh he's the new kid he's in
LA now right so he's just strolling
around we were like don't don't be
walking around he's you know I mean I've
never met the guy I don't know his
section we're both on the same show and
it's gonna tell of each other you guys
into the podcast and then he just
frickin was dropping some gems on me
because you know he's a seasoned that I
just kept dropping gems on the way he
writes and this club in this theater and
just what he does and just a really
really what do you then nicest guy in
the [ __ ] world I know it was amazing
man just such a good dude and so goddamn
funny so goddamn funny be guys he's got
some big guys yeah yeah he's a bit on it
so I don't but yeah he's feel thicker
huh yeah I lives full-time in Nashville
he does not New York you know lives in
Nashville I don't know how you I guess
if you're not acting you can do that you
have a following on the road you can get
up and do that yeah and that feels great
when I went to West's house
West and Jen's house there anymore I
know what a house though amazing right
see the land and stash and then they
have the two kids like oh no that makes
sense ah you see I get that feeling when
I'm in La Jolla I'm not just saying that
cuz I'm there this Thursday Friday
Saturday all shows are muscled out get
tickets now anyways if I did if I prize
if I didn't have our show and I didn't
need to
in a brown eye now town I know I have no
reason to be here I know in busy SLA I
would go straight to La Jolla I got by
house in La Jolla it's slow it's good
[ __ ] schools it's safe now hold on
now you're only about ten miles away
from the border where the cutting heads
off murdering people that's ten miles
away
it's Pleasantville to hit that [ __ ]
yeah nightmare performance all the
institutions break down that's right
III walk just kidding I like yeah I like
I [ __ ] I always fantasize about
living somewhere else besides LA I'm not
that attached to LA and I've been here
forever I am yeah my heart's deep deep
in LA like when I grew up in the summers
in Venice Oh max I'm so like I my best
memory for God yeah best memories are in
LA I forgot that you grew up in the
summer you spent your summers every
summer I forgot that kind of like
obviously I'm from Denver but mom you
found your way back here
oh dude that's he always wanted to live
here i dude I'm telling you I don't take
it for granted either at like last night
when are you done with the store I'm
driving down Laurel Canyon when I take
Topanga every morning
I love that man yeah I'm excited to
drive that I'd love to live in Northern
California I'd love to live in Nashville
there's certain places where I go Austin
I know there's parts of northern
calories like oh yeah Monterey oh he's
beautiful of Monterey up right [ __ ]
now I thought say right now I'm getting
annoyed dude have you been Oh Laguna
Niguel hell yes I've been I look good in
the gal dude I don't have anything for
all right now I'm excited so I'm saying
yes that's what I'll retire for sure Oh
God you see seals and elephant seals
great whites and I don't know but like
you have it's nice moderate just that's
where they do that ridiculous car show
yeah Monterey is amazing my dad and
brother go over here and don't invite me
that's where I was said I was in
Monterey and there was a I was with
friends and then they had their friends
come over with their son and their son
was five and as gay as a five year I've
ever seen in my life he was so
clearly it was even gay he was just
flamboyant and a girl I mean he you know
in his mind he was it was so interesting
like why yeah
it was stupid it was the conversation
but with his parents of a parent yes I
was like well there we go there's my
little there's my something like lady
with the you shall embrace it with my
little lady you know yeah and the dad
took it well too I always whenever I
think of Monterey I think of that
interesting yeah I don't think of the
gate five-year-old yeah have you seen
Dwayne Wade's kid no I'm not I her no
yes how about how about on Monday how
about a Monday right I got done doing
below the belt and Dwyane Wade was in
studio in Steph Curry seriously mm-hmm
and they had this food truck here that
this guy Matt Barnes who's like the
greatest guy as well he's the he's a
Nate bargatze of MBA he's the nice guy
Matt Barnes is phenomenal but just so
they have that show all the smoke that's
Matt Barnes yeah he's great great dude
yeah he is that show Steven Jackson it's
like the best show in basketball it's on
Showtime they've had crazy guests so
that all these basketball players I meet
us through them but they're this food
truck with it was chicken wings and
fried catfish and shrimp my mouth's
water now thinking about it so I was
planning to go and eat healthy with Todd
Feldman everybody thought filling I
supposed to meet him for lunch he
cancels like do not feeling good all
right and I'm like all right and I'm
sitting I look at the wings like those
look pretty delicious yeah dude I ate so
much couldn't tell you what Dwayne's
talking about can't tell you what the
interview is like so much I had to pull
over on Topanga Canyon throw up I'm
fasting all day and it was like 1:30 and
I'm like wow I eat a ton of food really
fast and I could tell because they're
like hey the director of the sugars hey
so if you're gonna just make sure real
quiet so I'm like trying to be quiet
dude I'm devouring up to you and you're
starving and it was like the best wings
ever ham just I'm talking I'm licking
bones I'm [ __ ] fries I got [ __ ]
fried catfish in my mouth you just
reminded me of like how when you know
one thing about a person you can't ever
get it out of your head I'll never
forget this girl
in my condo she was like hot and it
would be like as soon as she was in the
studio all of us are trying to kick each
other's [ __ ] heads off because ever
attended yeah it'd just be like we'd
spar like friendships are all break
apart it's like oh we're not friends I
just wanna look yeah you know and I'll
never forget I hear sometimes you just
get it and she just goes I know what cuz
we there was like a like a tent there
were other people there there was a test
the belt she goes she goes yes I'm like
you're treating like one of the guys and
you're acting like one guys I and I
could never take it on again get over a
date a girl like that I would tell you
I'm like dude how about she did ah man
date night is dating this girl I mean
this is years and years ago she blew up
my bathroom so bad came out and I she
was in there for a while but she jumped
in my bed my bathroom was at the time
was the one-bedroom small apartment so
the bathrooms right next to the bath she
blows it up it sounds like a goddamn
symphony in that bathroom I'm not
sleeping I will [ __ ] no [ __ ]
it's not no longer it's nine o'clock and
she was like ooh I know what she was ooh
kind of trots in the bath I'm like well
whatever I'm still watching just TV she
knows I'm right there doesn't try to
mask it or anything yucky you like flush
to it and then rip it and then hopefully
the sound like Hoth is a silencer huh
I'm gonna do that I know yeah see now
comes out and goes oh Jesus man like no
no that's a huge problem has that got
wet if I were a girl I'm going I'll go
outside I'll be like I left something in
my car I'll [ __ ] on the side of the road
before yeah I'll hike with yours and
[ __ ] elsewhere I did this I one time I
was in New York City and the girl was in
my it went it's a one-bedroom apartment
Haley the girl was sleeping in the
bedroom I was like the bathrooms too
close she's gonna to hear me take a [ __ ]
nothing worse I go into the [ __ ]
kitchen I take a plastic bag and
right in that plastic bag tie it up
smelled awful like I tied that thing up
ran out to the trash chute and threw it
out and I was like that's how you
sometime kitchen I'm reading up I
remember some horrible man oh man hey
don't tell people who are respectable
citizens don't listen to my podcast do
not know don't do it you'll hate earnest
don't don't do it
agree if you have any respect for us
don't listen I don't know I just you
know sometimes with hotels I'm like dude
what dude does not what to hate or
design this first of all it's a glass
it's a [ __ ] glass toilet next to the
bed dude that's annoying it's right
there how the [ __ ] are we gonna share go
lobby the lobby gotta go to lobby I'm
not taking this [ __ ] there I had one
time I know girl I was like um I was I
was going like I was washing my face so
you heard you always wash it's so late
she goes like this she goes he's clean I
keep my whistle would I keep my life
clean bro use wipe off you know that's a
better point they do have white bees
that you could flush them I do you I use
white bees and make sure my shredders
only hold on let me tell what this grown
51 year old man chetu he gets on the
sink like a gargoyle it's not with his
dick and peace out the front and I see
him splash water up his [ __ ] I've
seen that I'm not admit I don't know 70
times I'm not admitting that I washed my
ass in the sink I've seen it happen many
of times I don't get why you just don't
get a bidet III wanted a day but it's
you have to install it so I'll just be
myself you can just get the the you
basically just buy the lid that fit your
toilet and fault
the water just can't have a dirty
whistle I can't have a dirty whistle no
matter what I have to I get in the
shower whatever I do I clean my whistle
my whistles clean early it's just in
case just [ __ ] envelops that rub pole
I don't know why I just feel dirty if I
don't I refuse to wear light underwear
all blacks camos you're a lazy wiper huh
just defenseless I'll get arrested
you'll sit on a [ __ ] public John
without putting any twelfth paper down
either you don't
you know if you guys think about the
other day I was on the toilet in
Atlantic City in the hotel okay and I
was in the lobby I'm like there's a lot
of about a thousand one with ten
thousand people have sat on that tour
mutants that are playing the slot
machines with one seven arms 10,000
shits they've been sipping [ __ ]
peanut claws just [ __ ] all over this
yeah here's what you don't think of you
think of your ass every dude tucked his
dick onto the toilet
think how many tips of dicks have rested
on there and you have nowhere else but
you dig well see don't touch that part
will you just hold it I hold it too much
too much work
I will never let the head of my dick
that is the worst thing for me if I like
you know the inside of the bowl and the
head of your deal man I'm very squeamish
about about other how about last night
at the store right I'm in the bathroom
in the greenroom yeah and I'm taking a
peanut bat I'm taking a piss and run
what's in and I come right when he's
like I think he's washing his face like
his head he's doing something throwing
something away
yeah and I'm coming out I have see you
just got done handling my goddamn big
Johnson yeah
this giant dick right just got done
wrangle don't do that with your head
like that like I come out and without it
without a beat doesn't mean you know
most people like deep wash your hands I
mean [ __ ] meet him just [ __ ] like
it was [ __ ] commando-style yeah I
don't that's all I purposely don't wash
my own meter and I pray somebody's never
do it say some I did that the other day
it's my dick shooting one of the crew
guys I take a piss I walk out he goes
you don't want your hands like I don't
[ __ ] wash my hands FRP absolutely not
no if anything I'll wash my hands before
I touch my dick me too
or I'll wash my hands when I walk
outside the bath thinks that touched the
handle I heard somebody say I don't know
if it's true I heard somebody say you
can get warts on your dick if you've
been shaking a lot of hands and ever
since I heard that you get paranoid I'm
like what it not much bro say that's
[ __ ] I know public bathrooms are
intense they're intense they're intense
dude I just feel like I'm gonna
straight-up
fog with this nyquil I know I feel like
when the Python so do so bring up Seb
yuccas it's elderberry Syrah
I know this really III don't have bro
science I'll tell you the two things
that actually doesn't seem to really
work so all in the podcast nope
Seb you cos syrup honey Sarila sambucus
Oh sambuca sambuca switches which is a
company that it really does work
yeah and and then I do that with our
oregano oil you know elsewhere it's
robitussin no I know but that's masks it
I think this actually ludus so does
that's the palette so it's used for the
common cold the flu h1n1 is also used
for aids and boost in all foods used for
aids but now I don't know that
look it's used for back pain I want to
eat works though oh and like pain sinus
pain chronic fatigue see if it is Ella
very good for colds Brittany I want to
see howhow much bro science is very good
for colds many people consider the other
very plant one of the most powerful for
preventing and treating calls and
influenza and swear by its antiviral
properties on average that patients
receive the ellebra relief of symptoms
four days earlier than the group that
received the placebos here that's a big
deal
I really actually believe in it it works
for me I don't know and I and I noticed
it it works in the real [ __ ] dude real
medicine there's a reason why they have
it you know that's that's you're using a
look there's no doubt like when my neck
I took three [ __ ] advil feel way
better you can say whatever you saw
relaxers flexors fantastic way better
flex our flexor f FL EXO can you get her
over the counter you need a prescription
flexor those things work for a reason
well so that you know the stuffs good
like what you say and I've done a little
study on all the real athletes I know
from Luke Rockhold
you'd like when they are almost all my
like crowds [ __ ] ice baths everyone
today every one of them every football
player if you what LeBron uses he uses
anti-inflammatories and the night this
out the you look yeah I'll go with
longevity career yeah yeah yeah but if
you know if you dig me I take you guys
know I take a decibel the SIBO sometimes
the placebo though to see if I am
yeah yeah you know I where I just went I
just went with I was just like I got a
long way to go with my jujitsu you take
privates again no I haven't I've been
working I haven't had a chance get texts
from Higa Machado going use your Jitsu
then I'll get them I got a video of him
at the studio waiting for me you would
show up either sir I'll be there sellout
dude yeah I don't know dude trained now
I got a question we have to stop
everything right everything don't waiter
oh good all good you got little side
satchels you got those side sash holes
for peanuts or some pocket change change
really pocket Chandra peanut change I'm
your what kind of shoes are those those
the Air Jordans these would be a joint
six Travis cuts there what your Jordan
six Travis Scott right there the Chi lab
or something with six clad and that's a
nice word
kalau be another kind of lab those the
Caliph how did you get Arabic with it
because I got Arabic right now now oh
this wasn't tell you shut your boomer
mouth
yesin yeah there they are here's a
reason yeah yes go ahead try and get
those no but I would try and get them I
will please do or two but I want that
side satchel well do you have anything
in it can I check I have XE in there
please don't it's a little dry whoa hey
yeah there's cocaine yeah
dude while I was gonna tell you I even
have the perfect reason for you to start
TRT I'm glad I'm a number one reason to
what go to my Instagram chin and bring
up what's his name how about so glad you
brought this up so I thought it was a it
was a fake I can't tell you how many
communes of text me go dude do you think
he's on stuff I want excuse me
come up the guy who's best friends with
Batista look first of all look at his
[ __ ] arms look at the veins yeah who
is he playing that he's the Shred he's
Amaro he's a marble kick he's got a
great body phenomenal I mean I would
never have thought that guy I think
people are they think I'm hating them
I'm not hating on I think it's so dope
I'm saying I'll take these whatever
whatever program he's on all he's got a
great frame that's a fantastic body I
would love to be built like that well he
was born like this frames not
wasn't born with ah that's a good frame
though you know what I'm saying though
he's got a lot to work with no don't go
to before-and-afters no he was a super
nerd Silicon Valley yeah but I'm saying
his ability to put on muscle like that
is pretty impressive I'm going did they
have his work out on their chair it was
a part of getting hurts I want to look
like that how yet he reveals how yet
redic ridiculously shredded what's he
say he probably never lifted weights in
his life either looked like when he was
doing that sounding skinny
I mean thin nerdy dude his small
shoulders see where his shoulders look
huge not the bulk of you know here's the
thing though amazing even if he couldn't
look better couldn't look phenomenal
he looks goddamn happy with his forearms
I mean you see the sexist India in the
world now I think so no that was him -
that's him as Bryan Callen yeah you him
prey of some figures what's he say would
he do did he say what he did
I'm not sure that guy did a [ __ ] a lot
of a stack of gold Jim Stewart no he
said he he has a resources like trainers
if they haven't ista huh yeah obviously
you did amputee star like really good
friends yeah best friends yeah well no
yet I see well no you're not gonna get
gains unless you it's not like that yeah
I mean he probably put in it I don't
work nothing happy there's a ton of work
yeah but a lot of hard work a hard time
to go from what he was on Silicon Valley
to a Marvel [ __ ] superhero in a year
dang that's is so nice I'm sawing for me
too I celebrate that I think people
thought when I post I'm hating no no
we're like that without shutting down my
my natural testosterone production which
is the side effects I don't know he's so
worried about that no you shouldn't have
you know look at all the guys you old
[ __ ] you hang out with all those guys
around they seem fine yeah yeah there
you could took this semester Sloan right
now I'm getting on it this is the
craziest transformation that I've ever
seen
[Music]
anybody else and also by the way he's
working out the right way he's got
somebody who knows what the [ __ ] they're
doing
maybe well he said Marvel's paying for
it too so yeah whoo biggest studio ever
to pay for all this stuff yeah big boys
but but again who would hate on this guy
cuz hey you know if Marvel calls ikt
once you be the neck spine herb and you
put on 30 pounds of muscle you have a
year you have unlimited budget I'm going
nuts
of course I am I'd be all over it
I'm trying you think of anybody else
that's made that big of a transformation
ah all Ryan Reynolds did for a while did
ya miles off two guys in a was it two to
two girls there to play so it was yummy
as girls then you got on T V on TR tube
for sure T on testosterone for blade
Trinity that's to son hurt in fact I
think he was a little chubby kid when he
was younger he go no he had a soul patch
yeah yeah mitts back in the day you know
mm-hmm always funny though I always had
a sense of humor really really funny
yeah really funny he's just skinny there
but yeah he got jacked I'm trying to
think who else Hugh Jackman got man and
older he's older - Hugh Jackman for
Wolverine yeah but your Wolverine oh who
had a huge transformation John Travolta
in Saturday Night Live 3 or whatever the
[ __ ] check him out John 3
there's a huge transformation he went
from being uh what the [ __ ] it is I
don't know if that's a good example I
was one just like skinny though no no it
was pretty good like if you see him fat
like that yeah he's there and then but
some skinny he's young but he went from
they showed his body there and they
showed him before that which he was so
fat
well he was when he was younger yeah
yeah yeah weird
Stallone Travolta look it back in the
80s when it was cool to have a headband
and I tanked here some balls were in a
headband on the
for October Saturday Night Fever he has
them it was the trio Will Smith for uh
Muhammad Ali got jacked oh yeah okay
peel from Fresh Prince to Muhammad I'll
leave yes Smith he was jacked yep yes he
was
I can't think of it best but as far as
this do come from Silicon Valley to
Marvel superhero you're making a good
point it might be the best I've never
seen I was shocked I was I literally
thought it was a oh the dude from dress
apart the guy from Guernsey galaxy Oh
Chris Pratt yeah man he was using me I
think he wrestled in college so he was a
but he got fat and then he got yeah he
was fat but even that body's not it's
nothing near what kumail's body was
probably natural to whose natural oh
that's [ __ ] who say it's natural
Pratt no no no Jake no Jake Gyllenhaal
but he's like I don't know
that's super impressed Tom Hardy for
being that's true Steve Rogers skinny
gay all right
just didn't eat carbs that's mean Tom
Hardy for Bronson
we're tomahawks huh Tom Hardy for
warrior you did warrior oh my god hold
on that was him in the mechanical look
at how crazy he is how did he get down
the machine the machine is he's a crazy
person that's why he's a crazy person I
think he said that he ate an apple and
like a can of tuna guy and that's it
look at him he's a [ __ ] I try that
afterwards gentleman why dude he went
from 180 220 pounds then boss up to 220
holy [ __ ] keep going down chin so
fascinating man Brad your boy
Bradley has always been pretty muscular
oh that's what he's gay look at him I'm
Christian Bale hands down I don't know
how he's that good discipline is insane
I had insane I don't know you know the
discipline hated he said he goes I don't
I resent the fact that I he's just old
he he said I've I've always been ashamed
at being somebody who put makeup on and
made believe so I have to make it hard
on myself
makes sense Drake where uh Nick Jonas
you did your little small thoroughly
smart or respect as much in Troy brother
sure he's a nice guy
Jonas is bigger now I don't like real
skinny Jonas and that's healthier farm
but I cumin between if it's better there
for Sean Alaskan man is way funnier on
the left is a disaster it's such a good
actor Daisy
I love Kevin Kevin was always muscular
always a small small shredded big deal I
don't know what's gonna just always been
fat so this is a terrorist another
running of ideas yeah this right again
just always been there there's two party
that lost weight now that's that y'all
read it Wow
he's sir I mean Jimmy Kimmel was Michael
Moore's fat and fat Jimmy Kimmel lost a
lot of weight though yeah he did a lot
of weight looks good handsome I thought
Joey Diaz was almost 400 pounds like 2
or 280 now I think 273 I'm looking
forward to getting ridiculous ridiculous
I mean I can't wait to go on to
everybody's on trt except for me I'm the
only [ __ ] person but you couldn't do
it on the Goldbergs or off with all that
good I look great does that no be weird
your character if you just like real
he's a gym teacher teacher you have to
ride in this he talks about being jacked
I know we can't just show up J you have
to tell what you're doing yeah
be weird either you can go on some
morlin which produces your body produces
natural some Orleans no that's not gonna
work for you dude just go on now you
like cough syrup [ __ ] no get on HGH
and steroids Brian there's nothing you
can get on I don't know what your
trainer
Rudy you're really [ __ ] it there's
nothing intake that's gonna boost that
stuff I've got to take up yep cool it's
gonna do nothing for you at your age you
need HD it talk to specialists alone
take HGH and a shitload of deca dude and
shut the [ __ ] not deca dude don't make
me take deca dude you don't want that
you wanna be jacked enough but you don't
want that cuz I you won't be like
tomorrow I might throw it out here and
then we're gonna
a problem plus that plus I'm doing
jujitsu and boxing you know what I'm
saying
be cool but you know what I'm saying I
don't when you push me and then I get
froggy and then it becomes a whole
disaster right and then you got your
hands full
I'm not saying you don't beat me it'd be
so you guys look at me it'd be CGI ants
fall right it would be you with roid
rage I'm not done hey then you got your
hands full right maybe even later up
when I'm done you be dude I'm talking he
got ants Paul hey how long how many
times you think you have to go to
Machado before you use your black belt
you think four more times then post on
Instagram don't do do you think if you
get casted in Joker - you're eating your
black belt it's cast all right that's it
cast it and also don't don't make fun of
my process - my journey I don't like it
you're right everyone's journeys
different don't like everyone's journeys
different I'm gonna be first name is
Aston coaches you can I have a we have a
plan right now I'm working defense yeah
oh yeah so my my defense is great you
know you know you're in trouble so I
made with on the ground yeah you know
you're in trouble if heating goes hey
man Ashton Kutcher's can be in her
tomorrow and he needs somebody to roll
it you know you [ __ ] up by cooker
right he's a brown belt yes that's was
six four yeah he's also good doesn't
matter yeah he's gonna [ __ ] you up dude
and I want to be there for that yeah for
the game please now for now and if I
play his game yeah if I play his game
for now if I play his game yet what I
just want you get your black belt did
were you talking about fighting you talk
about you did say anything Kitsch was
gonna be chin it be quiet
look at that dude yeah he's been doing
for a while yeah man he got obsessed
with a girl he can tell me he's [ __ ]
good he's good
is that Connor yeah it's a side-by-side
gone on McGregor that's strange
oh wow City okay that's he can saying
that pitcher would beat Conor McGregor
in jujitsu maybe cuz he's so much bigger
in just pure jujitsu I don't know the
kind of McGregor's a wrestler
I don't partake in this go you know
Ashton Kutcher I know how long it's
taking I'm sure he has good skills for
regulars Jiu Jitsu said he's telling us
but when you're talking you still time
actor dad you anytime up the grind that
conrick gregor's been on yeah it's
almost but I love severe I love that I
love that about fighting right to me
let's I love I love I love the
difference I love the difference it's my
favorite thing I love I love [ __ ]
with you like that
hey you were a little serious though no
I was yes so dis I'm really not serious
I just like I just like getting you
going especially about something like
Conor because Conor's not known as a
wrestler but what people seem so just to
show you what I died you know this what
people don't realize is that for example
like with with khabib nurmagomedov he's
never gonna come at all
Norma come at off your [ __ ] mate oh
yeah that [ __ ] that takes
everybody and wraps him up well people
don't remember about the fight with
Conor even though he beat the [ __ ] out
of Conor is Conor kept him at bay for a
while by controlling his rest and stuff
because Conor had brought in a dude from
Dagestan in his training camp who
wrestled like that I still got taking
downs bindle promises you watchin y'all
Conor's just a box it get be your your
watch him against the very first battle
in the world so the combo so the oh he's
just a striker hold on
the guy has got to the top of the mount
at 145 155 you don't think he knows
grappling and he's also a hell of an
athlete he's a good fighter like his gym
he's doing wrestling with the best of
the best all the time
jiu-jitsu wrestling boxing does he give
I didn't know you could heroes with
dannis and that's pretty the best
friends that I mean that's they travel
the world together enroll if got
non-stop dannis is what 170 probably
sucks down mommy's 95 phenomenal
phenomenal grappler monster now for
doing a celebrity Jiu Jitsu tournament
I'll probably take a Singh Kutcher
against the rest of the other actors
yeah depending who it is yeah yeah all
actors want everybody every man wants to
think that they could do something until
they get it's like so this guy who is a
wrestler [ __ ]
and he he told me that he couldn't hack
it at Arizona State or ASU and I said
why goes everybody who is on that team
never lost in high school like everybody
who made it in d1 like that literally
lost like maybe twice in high school
they were all Allstars they were all
ridiculously good that's why they're in
that program so he said I was an amazing
high school wrestler and then I got
there and I was just getting it was just
you're just a guy just a guy just a
whole whole different thing
although Ohio State - I just hung with
two guys from Ohio State it's a whole
different thing that's all sports so
high level yeah everybody was good yeah
everyone's the captain the team everyone
threw for a thousand well one of the
things about last chance U is watching
what that and but the other thing about
guys are fuck-ups though there's but C
to get through a d1 program is much more
than just athletics - though it's also
like being able to deal with the
pressure not being your own worst enemy
now cuz there are a lot of great
athletes that don't make it through the
do you want program a lot of Grassley's
don't make it the NFL because they are
fuck-ups you know or you so many more
guys do because they're not fuck-ups
those guys self-sabotaging
that's all that last chance you should
be called [ __ ] fuck-ups yeah
everything just all them is complete
fuck-ups yeah but they're talented but
then they might not have a work ethic if
there's something that they just don't
get there and there's just too many
there's too many talented football
players on Florida State and Ohio State
who weren't gonna [ __ ] up top my acting
teacher math teacher jeffrey tambor east
always do this it didn't matter what the
[ __ ] he'd go but you're not ready what
happened you know cuz I had my there was
a fire and my dog was killed and you
know tears I think us this is he goes
this is so [ __ ] sad he goes I just
want you to know in your sadness you
needs to know this you know what we do
with people like you watch this this is
what happens I'm sorry everybody
I'm sorry I am so sorry about this and I
know this is I sound like a [ __ ]
because this person is going tonight and
this is a good person right you're going
through a lot and I do sympathize but I
want to show you what happens I want to
show you how what happens because I feel
like I'm a little um I throw right now
because I'm really sad for you
watch what watch this ready next 100% I
never forgot it
I never forgot it he went next oh and I
went that's that's right everybody
they're a bunch of guys like me waiting
in the wings
if you're not ready if you and that's
life the beginning it isn't that like
nobody gets to [ __ ] how about its next
how about see you my this my freshman
there's a battle for the quarterbacks it
was close man pull that pull that great
spring training camps and everyone's
like God who's gonna losing me the
starter man who's him it's very first
day fall camp though the one guy came in
a minute late what came a minute late
and you know it was like right when we
sat down but the the other guy was there
five minutes earlier with his notebook
you know it's closed and the coach
Burnett goes you do you know what time
it is and he goes yeah my watch says
it's 8 a.m. because it's 801 he goes oh
yeah I said here says a goes well we go
off this clock he goes Joel be the
starter that's it
judges too I was like give me one excuse
out give me one tiny excu worked out
with us the entire summer the tire
spring and lost the starting gig just
like I mean just like his watch was a
minute I was raised that way though I
was raised my dad that way dude dude I
mean my father said to me listen me
there are no excuses in the real worth
the boat is nothing wires
yeah the boat is pulling away but
doesn't matter the boat is as the boat
leaves the diet is you can't jump onto
the boat the boat Scott but I just
remember a biscuit this gallon says I
just remember its face like you worked
all springless worked at 5:00 a.m.
dirty dozens in the winter we're talking
that's summer work we live together I
said and then it's like dude you might
be the start of the CU buffs and then
just like that he's like I know I'm
asked me if I said yeah and then you
minute Joseph started her and I was just
like did he ever make it back to
starting though I don't know because
that that kid who he gave the starting
position to take advantage and just
bawled out and that kid just fade it
away [ __ ] when he had probably more
talent than the other guy [ __ ] just
faded I did that once I I was young and
I'm a [ __ ] idiot I I was full of that
stuff I was fooling ourselves I mean I
was full of that stuff so when people
talk to me it's like listen listen to me
because I was the
heavyweight champion of self saboteur
sabotage behavior because for whatever
reason I hate myself and I had a I had a
very good chance of getting talk soup
when it mattered talk soup when it not
in the back belly okay good because it
was by and you know I decided to be an
hour late
Wow yeah I was like you know I don't
know I'm gonna be an hour late because I
didn't cuz maybe I don't deserve it and
I'm a piece of [ __ ] yeah they weren't
the chair that's just I give me yourself
they weren't there they had left oh yeah
and I called my manager and he goes
Brian I wanted this for you and they
wanted it I was like I'm gonna get back
in my cabin was right for another 5-10
years yeah I would have I was listening
this I was interviewed the game and it's
weird how this worked out and then I was
shooting this other show was [ __ ] out
know he does have a giant I wish it was
distinct believe this guy was willing to
do that and I've never actually been on
listening fat ass dick ever but so he's
in this interview and he's time about
this big meeting head and just like real
casual he's like yeah you know me man
that's job about two hours late that's
all
but then he just like no one was like
hold up to but you know just keep
talking this big meeting that changes
life in his two hours late like yeah
that's weird and then I I was working on
something else and they work with the
game how's it were like what's it like
working with me like he's a great dude
man but he just you know you know he's
gonna be two or three hours late no
matter what we said a call time he's two
three hours late and I went
why the [ __ ] would he make it up with
that oh but also since that's a form of
saying [ __ ] you look if you're a grown
man it's a form of like totally how
nobody tells me what to do how weird is
it that sounds like dude you're two
hours late
that's a chip you know that's a chip
that's like that's a weird emotional
thing you know nothing saying to me yeah
I think for me just gonna work like if
you're two hours yeah it's just like
okay for me the reason I was always late
I didn't want to act as I look did you
like act and now like dedicate your life
yeah I like stand up I like comedy I
like comedy but what I would I realize
is that so much of my
behavior was the fact that I I didn't
want to be an actor I wanted to be a
goddamn stand-up comic you know you came
to LA for I came to a light it be Robert
De Niro Christopher Walken Al Pacino
whatever it is and then you fell into
stand-up right I just realized I was
funny and that I I wasn't gonna be
working as much because of so many
things I mean look don't get me wrong I
worked hard I tried hard III did okay
but some of it was just bad luck because
some of it was getting shows that didn't
go and all that stuff so yeah so it's
not that I didn't work hours worked hard
and I was showed up you know but but I
do think that in your life sometimes you
will you will say you want something and
and you'll [ __ ] yourself up on purpose
because it's not ultimately what you
want to do there's that yeah yeah yeah I
mean I don't know I mean maybe think
about or or you thought you were gonna
do something's gonna be like these guys
can go like this it doesn't go that way
they're not awful if you had a dad who
said hey Brendan I know you're built for
sports but you're gonna sing and dance
and you're gonna you're gonna plant
instrument now I don't know what would
happen with you because I don't know if
that would have been the best course for
someone like you because you got a lot
out of sports your work ethic self pride
so we've always been there even yeah
yeah but I wonder with you I wonder what
I wonder if you would have missed sports
I wonder if someone like you III I don't
think you would have rejected like you
know I think that you would have put so
into like an instrument piano I don't
know
you know improv theatre idea and it's
whitby where'd you learn Denver you know
it's like not well that's what I'm
saying is that you didn't grow up in an
environment that supported that idea but
if you had grown up in an environment
that supported saying in in an in in a
New York family a Jewish intellectual
New York family that said [ __ ] sports
you're gonna be an artist yeah that'd be
cool and you had a lot of support be a
gay man yeah you'd be just a giant game
an artist yeah you'd experiment with
[ __ ] and with drugs but more [ __ ] and
stuff and I definitely the easier let oh
you'd be a thick jared leto you'd be
wearing clogs right now in a dress and
on my lap and it would finally be happy
yes
yeah live in our crew yes truth in our
truth it's good at current events man
hey dude it's the holiday sometimes
people get sad around the holidays I
have an idea yeah he gets at around the
holidays need somebody to talk to you
not a friend
yeah not your parents yeah your grandma
yeah we'll save it for a professional
man but you don't have to drive anywhere
you can do it from your home from your
bedroom from your cell phone I'm talking
about better help with a licensed
professional yeah help calm is there for
you because sometimes you don't you
don't know who to talk to you don't know
who to turn to you don't know where to
get advice from but you want somebody
who's a licensed professional who knows
how to professionally counsel it's done
securely online there's a broad range of
expertise and better helps counselor
network for all kinds of problems it's
not a crisis line though no it's not
self-help it's a professional counseling
done securely online all right you can
log into your account anytime send a
message to your counselor you'll get
timely and thoughtful responses you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
you don't have to sit in our waiting
room oh man plus it's a more affordable
than traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is also available visit
better help calm slash fighter and join
the over 500,000 people taking charge of
their mental health with the help of an
experienced professional front of kid
listeners get temps off your first month
at better help calm slash provider
listen if you're looking for stuff for
your brain if you're looking for stuff
for your mood in your sleep your
digestive health your support and
vitality if you need self and general
generally essential nutrients if you
want something for performance yes your
immune system yeah honest got this
shroom tech immune they've got biotech
people swear by for performance shroom
tech support which I actually use you to
happen about you're not here t thanks to
on it
nothing shot you might shut the creatine
when I got mineral electrolytes when I
got bait out only when I got total
strength you also got access to all
their fitness gear all their apparel
everything dude you want work out at
home cool on it six can do it you can
start working out from just your goddamn
cell phone in your living room whatever
you want you got body weight training
you got
about training a steel maze training you
got streaming fitness classes it never
ends also what a great gift idea on its
supplements everybody like thanks dude
on it doc on slash fighter temps enough
the entire dam site enjoyed let's do
some current events I tell you cat I
love the way you look today you are
you're always very adorable but you this
is a good outfit on you chin thank you
for covering your head let's see welcome
we were Brenda and I were singing both
of your praises the other day privately
we like you guys thanks a big part of
the show thank you so I don't know how
to pronounce this name but a somebody
eavesdropped on private messages within
southern italy 'he's Rich's crime
syndicate and they found that there was
actually a ban on gay men joining the
mafia for a long time that was recently
lifted because one of the largest crime
bosses within that syndicate found out
that his son is actually an amazing drag
queen that goes by Lady Godiva a good
diver well I'm not gonna tell them off
you what to do here and I'm certainly I
sell the Italian mafia what to do hey
imagine being this [ __ ] mob boss at
the meeting like I got some propose I
don't like kind of no gays in here but I
don't know man
just cuz his son just trying to open the
door I call [ __ ] on this story yeah
this is a trolling story Barstow ours in
Calabria I don't think so also here's
the other thing with the Mafia they're
not gonna do a press release that
they're linked gays in them now it's
gonna be no media no they're not and
also they're not hold on the color
karate told The Times that although
homosexual is still taboo among older
bosses the Mafia III don't think any
real mafia guys can be talking about
this the source the time of his opens
doors gay members that mob us living as
fast man there are mob bosses living as
a drag queen
I know bosses son we have a picture of
the sign they said that the only search
that they found under the name Lady
Godiva for a drag queen was this
gentleman right here wait one more right
there
but it is not confirmed there you go
that's a handsome woman
yeah that's a rough-looking drop one I
don't know if I buy it either now the
mobs definitely like definitely knows
what this press right even if they did
allow out anyone would have the New York
Mafia you couldn't be black you couldn't
be gay yeah baby a woman kidding it
another no I can't be there to trace the
racist it is all your route go back to
the city you're from
come on you find after your dad was a
snitch you know yeah well you know what
I'm [ __ ] sicyon well you can't give
the mob now cuz you're gay got me what
else we get so Brendan I think you
actually retweeted this Antonio Brown
came out with a tweet saying like he's
on this campaign hashtag no white woman
2020 and I think this is alluding to the
mother of his children and a lot of
people are saying that the only reason
why he's doing this is because he's
trying to start a career in music now
that football isn't going well for a
mess wait say this is just crazy
he's a little bit crazy so Antonio Brown
went on Twitter and he basically said no
more white woman in 2020 and people
think that this is alluding to the
mother of his three children but ever
since everything he's been doing with
the sexual assault allegations the
terrible that he's been doing in the NFL
now he's actually turning to make music
so he's trying to be a rapper now so
he's not gonna play football he's still
trying to get signed a playoff team but
no so he's just basically doing you
gotta sign him to a playoff team you got
to do I mean can they do that in the
middle can they drive you not drive I
mean if I'm if I'm if I'm yeah just
[ __ ] sign of miles you can use him
his speed and his competitive spirit
he's a crazy nut so he's a nut so he
ruins teams like the chemistry and [ __ ]
like he's a complete diva
also these the sexual alligator
tough to deal with and I was doing this
no white man can you are the white women
the ones that got him in trouble that's
what he's claiming but I mean the
painter who accused him of like missbach
yeah she's yeah the trainer was black
too so I'm not quite sure where he's
coming he's just crazy ideas great I
wouldn't want my team but he also can so
he's doing a music video which he mean
[ __ ] terrible he's doing a music
video right in a rap video and he's
making fun of hashtag no white woman can
you imagine being a white girl answering
that casting call right I'm sure he
didn't a hundred and thousands of pretty
white girls with like what the [ __ ] he
do yeah mm-hmm he's an idiot what is yet
okay
so last week there were four large
incidents with ring alarms being hacked
and a lot of people have the footage
ready because ring consistently just
keeps recording where the camera is
located some people like to put it on
the outside of their homes to see people
with packages or people at the front
door but some people also like to put it
on the inside of their home so they can
see what their kids are doing and the
video that I saw that went viral was
basically this little girl is playing in
her room all of a sudden some Christmas
music comes on and a man's voice
pretends to be saying that and talk to
him is this the one really I was doing
anti-semitic things like don't tell your
mom it was uh no is that that's a
different one wears a black family some
[ __ ] nerd like some bad person hacked
into it it was like go tell go call your
dad
the n-word don't call your dad horrible
man yeah but this girl this is scary man
this one's scary I'm your best friend
I'm Santa Claus I'm Santa Claus so what
you want to be my best friend
terrible man yeah the original video had
a couple seconds after where he starts
saying oh it's okay to go destroy you
like break your TV do this do that and
he's basically just trying to make her
comfortable let her do what she wants
are they tapping into this thing ring
actually doesn't know but they catch you
and get into your account that is a big
concern right now because a lot of
people use the same username and
passwords for different accounts so if
they have the password to let's say like
your Facebook yeah my brain was like
people were like dude this ridiculous
well they're getting your password they
can't hack into our system yeah that
thing's bulletproof they're they're
getting they find out your path so you
got to change your path on yeah yeah
it's terrible man but I think about that
sorts a grown man that did that how
weird is that man it's weird
[ __ ] strange people you got nothing
else to do get into somebody's house and
talk to a little girl great online they
cache the [ __ ] no not yeah they would
get trace in the eye
I feel like ring is probably working on
something right now trying to locate
where the hacker signed in from IP
address but I don't know if I can see
you in bed come on wake the [ __ ] up that
was a woman I believe in Texas you guys
up in the middle of the night to UM man
scream like I'm in your bedroom right oh
my god that's insane that's absolutely
insane yeah Courtney Cox a lot of people
says she looks just like Caitlyn Jenner
I just saw her at the store she's doing
uh David Spade where they they tell
celebrities did you stand up oh don't
let you do a celebrity real comics Larry
real comic never earpiece in have you
seen that being now and then like
Whitney Cummings or and David Spade and
Courtney Cox were in the back like
whispering joke to tell them to stay on
stage it's pretty fun really yeah I like
corn add friends were there she's good
people but she's yeah she she was she
made fun of herself here so this is her
post there's a bunch of people saying
she looks like Caitlyn Jenner
and then she wrote this so she's having
fun with herself I mean I mean there's a
some similarities yeah you know yeah a
little bit of vibe here that's right all
right this is actually kind of funny
this caricature drawing you know those
guys this is in Riverside this is a
Riverside so this guy that guy said like
did that do look like that but yes so
the guy that was some guys sat down next
to the character guy drawing and then he
did his picture and then right at the
end of it the guy that would did his
picture took his money back for five
hundred dollars so this is the the
drawing of the guy that they're going
after right now this is all the proof
that they have so that's what he looks
like
hey soos treho all right well there you
go
there you go did you guys know about the
controversy of hallmark and the same sex
yeah homework being a bunch of [ __ ]
the night came out they had two girls
kissing yep in their ad and this for a
wedding registry decided to cut it but
then that came out that they cut it some
people like dude what's wrong with you
now who gives a [ __ ] especially on 19
what are you doing homework it was also
just a peck it was really fast it was
like a silly spot to if there's light
hearted man is that it yeah you wanna
watch it yeah I ever wonder if our
guests would be here on time if we had a
custom wedding website with our ceremony
details on it and I Taylor would pick
Sola to have it to host our wedding
website ours even matched our Sola
invites the whole thing was so freakin
easy do you think Zola could have made
planning your perfect wedding easier we
do
we've helped a million couples plan
their weddings with free web stack
invitation a deep kiss I'm happy for you
guys you guys want me to head in did you
guys sure about this gay there you want
somebody to change your mind yeah I
don't
okay let me officiate that wedding but
am I not there but if you female halt
you think about who [ __ ] with Hallmark
you say that's a huge company huge so
they're like Aiden what the backlash
company yeah Mark said that this one's
is it worth it to you you know they'll
make more money saying they're men they
make more money scrapping it tell you
that much people are still conservative
in this what they put about they're
gonna work to put it back on air now
because of the huge backlash there's
like 30,000 signatures to get it off by
a conservative group called 1 Million
Moms and so that's what prompted that
get him off because they said they don't
want controversies so has nothing do
with that they just don't want just
don't want the controversy but then now
of course they were working to bring it
back because there are 70,000 signatures
to bring it back to people love each
other I'm not getting in the way of that
yeah it's not a big deal I'm also not
buying Hallmark cards anymore does
anyone even watch the Hallmark Channel
no I didn't know there's a channel but
oh yeah [ __ ] cards anymore that's
they got a card you text people never
how about that I don't even like getting
cards I think it's such a we never have
them you what do you do with those yeah
people still send me you know my family
thumb only you text me this is just
going viral because I guess they're
making fun of how the you know Leonardo
DiCaprio dances and there's that P
Diddy's birthday does that learner in
the hell yeah
[Music]
I'm more worried about pretty much it I
just having a good time having a good
time but also dance and dance really yes
seems to be a breakdown back in the day
huh
we haven't do it dancing at raves and
stuff like that yeah he loves that lave
stuff yeah
trance music break hi yeah it's right hi
[ __ ] yeah and just goes crazy with light
sticks I think he's great dressed
exactly that way half code Jamie Foxx oh
yeah I got a buncha names that I know I
don't long talk with mr. Fox nice guy I
was gonna huge fan is so talented man
he's so talented
well [ __ ] one more I have I'll tell you
about that story off air they went away
so it's Akashi six nine he was sentenced
to only two years and er served 13
months of it so he's gonna be out next
year they thought he didn't get out
today though oh really yeah Oh even this
is like dannegan two years but he had 47
he was supposed to at 47 years of bad
[ __ ] attempted murder was involved
somehow an attempted murder yeah the
traffic yeah you know he's got a price
on his head for turning on everybody but
he the biggest problem is that tattoo of
those tattoos on his head and face her
how about he turned down witness
protection and security is acknowledged
hi Milan security government else
oh cool man yeah you got this how you
gonna protect him anyway he their
witness protection doesn't work with
that [ __ ] guy he's got tattoos all
over his face he's very easy to see I
mean his face is already super
recognizable regardless yeah he's I mean
what are you gonna do do but he's only
getting two years so 13-month crazy
thank you yeah 20/20 how funny is
Charlemagne goes if he oh yeah he's
trying anything Charlotte you know
Charlamagne tha God with Andrew Schultz
you put Charmaine was on practice good
because if he said I forget what his
deal is he goes but if he gets out I
will suck his yeah he said this right
when I went down he goes dude if he gets
out I think before it's certain like if
he gets up 4921 I will suck his dick
yeah no questions a good of all the
charges
I'm just gonna write suck dick wide
Charlemagne the guy why is he calling
something god that's a weird there's got
to be some history to it though yeah if
he beat the ratchet energy hates it he
beat it everyone's like you oh my dick
suck why he goes dude I was just [ __ ]
being condescending like he beat it he
he ended up playing out right this is
nobody did he beat it Doug cuz he was
looking at 40 years yeah 47 47 win but
he turned he turned against he put a lot
of people in G again he was so mad worth
coming with information that's why they
sang like a canary oh yeah well by the
way if they look at you in your young
man they go you're gonna go away you're
gonna you'll be out when you're sixty
okay those guys are all gonna be in jail
and dead anyway so look if Takashi's
exciting beats this case that will suck
his dick and he doesn't even have to ask
me he'll be out make sure he beat the
case your sucked at his damn phone he
goes dude I was being [ __ ]
condescending oh good god oh well here I
play that yeah xxx is still alive don't
do it okay now worth it if Takashi 6-9
if the coffee 6-9 beats this case okay
hey this one put the king is being
released this week
y'all faves ain't ready the charge ain't
ready Charlemagne sure as [ __ ] his wife
that's a Nicki Minaj document always
they did a song together yeah his
girlfriend looks like that though she's
like black Angie's his face is
ridiculous
great it's what the kids are doing these
days face that is have you seen post
Malone yeah he says I always tired and
those tattoos all over here
I can see I see that Jen yeah she's a
hottie though she's mister pretty nice
though which one I got a tattoo of his
face on her chest the gang that he's
[ __ ] with and snitched on the trail a
chance trail ways up the probably get to
her I would imagine it's a nightmare for
everybody who who are they
he's fun was the gang anyway blood slip
York in New York yeah it's a not a good
thing no on top of that he has a baby
mama and a daughter too that's all
is that tattoo real yes they're all
unfortunately she's hot as [ __ ] she is
if she is stunning but those are
terrible tasks I know because she's
gonna they're not it's not gonna last
and then she's another guy's gonna jump
on there and go you have to take those
[ __ ] things off don't they jump on
there though you know okay sorry I stuck
it streets [ __ ] she's super hot but just
terrible decisions huh god Lucy's making
sweats because he is making he's always
made smart decisions good as he has a
rapper lyrics aside maybe I'm just old
he's not [ __ ] comparing like J :
Kendrick he has some some jams but I
don't lift it I guess weights do it you
know it's around here no it's too
hardcore for me have you ever seen his
video no can we show Brian his it's the
one where it's all the Bloods and he's
shooting it and it's like they're all
Bloods umm this is going to his page oh
yeah that one this is this is this is a
pretty funny there's such a boomer but
here's the I feel like it but look at my
face like I'm like look at the guns and
all that that just looks fantastic huh
yeah safe so he turned on all he's got
his body's terrible
here's the worst body effort but here's
the thing about all this how crazy that
he was making millions off whether you
like his making music or not I'm not
crazy about it Tara buddy he's making
terrible he's making millions and
millions of dollars from his music
all millions a million dollars and then
this dude because he wants to live that
gang he never really gave me one sweet
lived a game Jeff well he also Spacely
signed a deal with the devil because he
went to tray way and they gave him like
protection was tray way the gang the
Bloods second I'm told you now keep up
boomer sorry but they told him if you're
in the music videos and you put us to
music videos will protect you like build
up your Street credit so in he goes I
wanna be a real gangster but all along
he's making money being a rapper
millions of dollars didn't need to do
any of that doesn't matter he wants to
look just wanted to live your life can
he wants feel tough yeah and yes you
know he's looking at prison for life and
hit the snitch on all these dudes now
yeah that's what a [ __ ] what a tragic
story I know just he's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
having a joker in his life an older man
is like like a dad to be like hey dude
oh excuse me sit down for a sec you're
being a [ __ ] idiot
God let's start with all the six nine
tattoos why is he called
Takashi six not that's just the name
that he gave himself Takashi
his actual name is David Hernandez go go
back he's Mexican I think ah no he's
Mexican max I think he's Mexican go back
to into his pro his to his page to the
YouTube oh there's his page together
they point four million subscribers is
it not yeah there's just such a track
like I'll see the [ __ ] idiot he's a
colorful guy it's just such a [ __ ] I
mean you had to do you want to be famous
that you had ever a [ __ ] it all up
there's a lot of self you know the dead
there's a lot of self-hatred in there I
mean there's some deep [ __ ] going on
obviously deep [ __ ] I mean most know
almost all his music videos a lot of
those have almost a billion views well
you know say we will about the kids
getting their faces tattoo but did their
psychologists have done those studies on
like the number of suicidal people who
are suicidal who get face tattoos is
really high they didn't redo the study
because because I disagree that that's
me back in the day when prisoners were
getting gang has to get it now it's a
fashionable thing it may be a
fashionable thing but I still think I
still think that that's is still next
in fashion like it's still kind of a
bingley update the research that it is
now it straight like when you think
about tattoos in general have it littles
an I thought he is he dead no no he just
became a father
he's like nineteen if a lot of them are
hardcore drug addicts like prescription
drugs yeah I do know a lot going on
there man
let's see this night just go to scroll
through these [ __ ] people look at
that always go on my one yeah a lot of
them are fun I mean well here's the
here's thing about post Malone doesn't
do any drugs smoke cigarettes and only
drink spare huh hey yeah that's
interesting that's that's a swastika I
means the Buddhists and yeah I
understand yeah
trippy red well it's become such a trend
now with these young like SoundCloud
rappers there that says they could face
that too
it's a terrible idea that's this weird
trend that everyone's getting now that
is just because you know tattoos used to
be like when you see someone with huge
like sleeves above oh but now it's like
nothing the fate as I stand out know
what I mean every scene anyone with a
face tattoo it man that's sick that is
lo p-type oh yeah that's what it passed
away oh this guy is crazy like he
actually has that tattoo yeah he's legit
crazy though Wow yeah
Kevlar D which I mean she's a tattoo
artist mm-hmm guy so just a bad idea
wow that guy got the same one isn't that
is manga the same face that Tuesday's
little Saint Saens
lows ant-man like xanax that's fake
that's real that was a real sweat that's
guy who died yeah what he died from
overdose it must be overdose overdose
yeah I don't know that he's suicide
little peep that's his name yeah I mean
he used to date Bella Thorne Donna
yeah I don't know if you face that to
just I'm just signing what I'm gonna get
you know yeah because I don't want
something that I want to get something
that's subtle
maybe I'll get the 10 million downloads
tattoo that's four years ago oh yeah
get a little haze tattoo yeah little
haze hearing boomer down from here down
to there and then and then how about
just gay yes no you know
a like an arrow ah I know better this
guy's right guys yes yes guys and then
just with a dick you're going right like
there is that too much do you think the
other do get in the airless as [ __ ] hole
[Laughter]
color come home one of the other hey
guys come see me this Saturday at the
celebrity theater in Arizona me Frank
Caliendo and Adam Rea this Saturday
Phoenix the celebrity theater and then
Boston
we still got tickets left for the will
who use make it or lawyers I'm excited
I'm in La Jolla tomorrow Friday Saturday
that is Thursday Friday Saturday La
Jolla comic store all shows almost sold
out get your tickets now
that's the comic store in La Jolla next
then [ __ ] ya next week even though it's
Christmas but next week Friday I'm oak
Oklahoma City two shows just on Friday
that's December 27th then December 28th
in Tulsa I'm the Hard Rock Casino there
and tolls up one show one night only and
then just hit the charts
New Year's Eve I'm at the ice house
Pasadena two shows one at 8:00 one at
10:00 me and some funny friends come pop
some bottles bringing 2020 the right way
the stickers going fast Ice House
Pasadena New Year's Eve December 31st
and then January come in hot January
10th I'm at Foxwoods casino Connecticut
January 11th Boston Wilbur theater has
less than 50 tickets get your tickets
right now t fat K calm then I'm closing
out January at San Jose improv tik calm
I just got this from Chris D'Elia I had
the same taxi - red zone you tried um
yeah I'm gonna write back [ __ ] you yeah
cool it dude t pack a gun for Brian and
myself see this is the fighter in the
kid we're out